hey what's up on today's show we talked
to a wife who is running all over her
husband
and she wants to know how she can stop
and help him step up
we also have a hard conversation about
the realities
of being married to an alcoholic
finally we talked to a young man who's
living with his girlfriend
a baby on the way he's a christian she's
an atheist
what is he to do stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up it's with the dr john
daloni show
taking your calls about your life your
marriage your relationships your kids
schools
that annoying neighbor all of it
so glad you're here i'm glad you're here
james zack i'm glad you're here
kelly's not glad by much anything she's
just nicknames eeyore
um she is glad about 80's glam metal
though
that gives her joy um but you know what
she's even glad you're here right and if
you're new to us
man you come to the right place we talk
about everything here
relational iq mental health challenges
and diagnostics
talk about um man treating people right
taking care of your wife or your husband
or your kids we talk about everything
and we entered a new man we just passed
like the 70 episode marks if you've been
with us
since the beginning where that's even
awesomer
hopefully the show's gotten better if
it's getting worse
so we've entered the post
no commercial world
it's a commercial time kids so today's
commercial is for
this new gym it's not really new it's
been out for a few months
if you've heard me say it man i had
really low expectations for this book
redefining anxiety
it's a quick book that i wrote about
just debunking the nonsense around
anxiety
the nonsense about this anxious time
period we live in
and then what you can do just get your
life back and
we thought i thought it would sell a
thousand copies a couple thousand
it sold tens of thousands we've had to
go back and and do a third pressing
and here's the thing now i'm starting to
get notes from counseling offices around
the country
um from like a college medical clinics
buying books in by the chunk man so they
can give them to students give them the
young people give them to adults who are
struggling with some of these things
it really distills everything down it's
10 bucks at johndaloni.com
pick up 49 copies um that's only 490
i just don't buy that many if you have
that much anxiety should probably go see
like somebody like
a real therapist but um get one for all
of your friends guys if you want the
perfect gift for your girlfriend
valentine's is coming up
nothing says i love you like here's a
book about your mental health
um that will help valentine's go super
great for you so um
hey dads if you don't want your
daughters
making out with somebody on valentine's
buy them a book about
their mental health tell them to read it
that night and it i don't know that
might make it worse but
anyway um give me a call at one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one that's one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one if you wanna be on the
show
or go to johndaloni.com show i love to
have you on we're getting emails and
calls from all
over the planet and it's just
extraordinary
it's extraordinary both in the depth and
challenge of what people are going
through but also
some of the common themes that are
running through everything people are
stressed they're exhausted
they just want to be loved they just
want to be known their marriages are a
wreck
we're just seeing the same things over
and over again you are not alone give us
a shout
can't wait to talk to you so let's start
off first let's go to uh let's go to
annika in tucson arizona annika what's
going on how can i help
hi dr john deloney what's up dr annika
how can i help
um so my question today is how do i make
my relationship with my husband
more equal when i have the stronger
personality
and i'm the pusher in the relationship
just off the top of my head i would say
don't be a pusher but
we could probably dig into it so tell me
what's going on
what's your what's your question beneath
the question
my question beneath the question is that
i really i dominate the conversation and
i am the pusher
and i'm i set the to-do list and i set
the goals and i feel like
i hold him accountable and more often
than not
i feel like mom but this is all from me
he doesn't feel this way we talked about
this when
um a couple of weeks ago he doesn't feel
this way but i just feel unbalanced like
he's not
an equal part of this relationship
when did he become less of a man in your
eyes
i don't know that i would say that i
would say it's gotten better
since we got married he's he's just
before you got married
i guess though he he doesn't come from a
strong family background his
him his mom likes to call it passive
aggressive okay
and he's just a very calm
peaceful person and i'm just a strong
red personality
so you have a picture of what a quote
unquote man is supposed to be in a
marriage and he's not living up to it
and you're trying to cover you're trying
to bridge that gap
by going over the top and either he's a
wimp or you're crushing him
or both or he's not a wimp at all he's
just a laid-back guy
that doesn't get stressed out about a
lot of stuff which sounds like he is a
walking xanax to you
the drama that you bring into every
single room but there's a picture that
you have of a guy and he's not living up
to it when did that change
or did it not ever you just hope you
would you would he would turn into it
i guess i'd somehow hope that he would
rise up and meet my level of
doing and being and
i don't know productivity and i guess i
always just
assumed that he would and but he's not
and he's not supposed to be he's
supposed to be
not me yeah you're exactly right so he's
not supposed to be you but
if he's not working and if he just wakes
up in the morning
and smokes a joint and then plays
video games all day and then you go to
work and you come home and you have to
do the laundry and cook dinner and all
that
yeah dude he's a bum he needs to get up
and get to work man he needs to
contribute
if he's a guy that he likes his 40
000 a year job he goes to it every day
he works good he gets good reviews but
he doesn't want to be vice president he
just likes his life
and he loves you um
then he's not living up to the this
imaginary thor that you were hoping he
would
morph into right who is he
um he's a full-time student and a
full-time worker he works like this at
the hospital and goes to school during
the week
and what's he going to school for he's
finishing his undergrad in biology and
wants to go to medical school
okay um
he's he's a great human he's he's a
wonderful husband he's a wonderful
father to our kids and
and i i don't know i think our
relationship is
pretty good except for the fact that you
said i just steamroll over him and i
just
so why do you do why do you do that
i don't because i i guess you know why
why are you standing is that
well i like to be productive and i like
to get things done and i like to
set goals for the future and i stick to
plans when i make them and
but so you've got a guy who's a great
dad who's going to school full time so
he can become a medical doctor and he's
working nights
what else do you want him to do
i don't know sometimes he doesn't stick
to his study plans and
he doesn't move forward with these goals
that he has
and i feel like i have to hold him
accountable to that to get him to
get where he wants to be like i have to
be his
life coach does he want to get there
does he want to get there or do you want
him to get there
he says he wants to get there
tell me about where you come from i
don't
see it where tell me about where you
come from
what do you mean like walk me through
how was mom and dad growing up
um my
dad is he's very firm but he's also
pretty peaceful my mom is similar to me
she's got a very strong
opinionated personality as do most of
the women in my family
sure um i think your husband probably
married you because you have a strong
fun loud personality right
i would hope so that's a beautiful fun
trait that's not something you need to
take away
right that's awesome um so
tell me about your old man
um he puts his foot down and
he doesn't budge once he gets to us my
mom can push and talk
and and and she
they they have a very equal relationship
but he also has a spot where he says i'm
not
changing my mind i'm not moving and
we're gonna compromise
where we are because i'm not changing
and is that what you want your husband
to be
i i guess i just want him to
set his goals and get there and not feel
like
i have to get him there so
the the hard truth is you can't get him
to his goals
he's gonna have to do it
and the more you act like his mom the
more he'll let you
be his mom and over time
no mom wants to be intimate with her son
and no son wants to be intimate with
their mom
and you've got kids so your kids are
going to take up
for both of you the affection part
because you won't be there for one
another because
you will be running his life and he will
simply let you
because it's exhausting to fight or he's
just not a fighter
then you're gonna wake up and be two
inches apart on a couch and two thousand
miles away from each other
or you can ask him what do you really
want to do and if he doesn't want to go
to med school then he's not going to go
to med school
if he does want to go to med school and
he flunks a class he's not going to get
in
right and then he's going to have to
change plans and what i would tell you
is if he really wants to go to med
school he won't flunk a class he'll show
up
what goals do you think he's missing
i think it's been a hard couple of years
for him and a lot of rejection
and now he's he's dealing with
depression and he's dealing with
all of this rejection that he's gotten
who's rejected who's rejecting him
we applied to over 20 schools last year
for med school got for med school and
got one interview
and then wait listed so we've been
working for this and hustling for
six years and there's just
a wait list at the end yeah
and so what i mean that's
traumatic that sucks
and is there a part of you that is
blaming him for that what did he do
to get weightlifted was he not good
enough he didn't try hard enough
he's not he's not as dedicated a student
he prefers
to be home he prefers to be with
the kids and he prefers to make memories
with them and not
study so
his grades are lower and he's not
getting into med school is that is that
the result
that's what i worry about but he still
says he wants to
so at the end of the day i feel like i
have to be the one that says
okay when are we sending out this letter
and when are we going to call these
people and when are we going to do this
because you want to go on let's go and
we got to do and
so here's the thing annika your husband
doesn't want to go to med school
or maybe he wants to want to be a doctor
i want to be a multi-millionaire so bad
but i don't want it
to the point that i'm not going to be
there for my kids games and i don't want
it
to the tune of not being around my wife
at night because i like hanging out with
her
and i think it's time for a conversation
if you get in by the way getting
wait-listed to med school i've done
research i've worked with med school
like
that doesn't mean he's not getting into
school i would still keep your options
open
but when i look at one of the core
phrases that guides my life is that
behavior is a language
and i often don't listen to what comes
out of people's mouth i do on this show
because i can't see you
but in my day-to-day life i listen less
to what comes out of people's mouth and
i just watch them
right and when my when i'm like hey son
let's go fishing don't you want to go
fishing he's like sure dad
and then he drags his feet and then i go
in his room he's like are you ready and
he's playing legos
he's telling me he don't want to go man
he just wants to stay at home and i can
press on him and i can lean on him be
like i thought we were going
and he'll be like yeah sure dad he'll do
it for me because he loves me he doesn't
want to disappoint me
but he don't want to go and then there's
days that it's like
six o'clock on a saturday morning and i
finally get up the courage to sleep in
and he's banging on the door
let's go fishing and he's already
dressed up got his hat on got his poles
and i know dude he's ready to go fishing
right
and so you've got to catch 22 here
you have what millions and millions and
millions of women in your same situation
would crave which is a husband that's
not afraid of hard work
a husband that would loves and loves to
make memories with their kids
but also got way down the road on
something and all of a sudden went
this is a lot more than i thought it was
going to be
and so at some point you either he's
going to get into a school
and it won't be the school that you all
dreamed of it's not stanford but it's
going to be a med school
when he graduates they're going to call
him a doctor and he's gonna have to
decide if he wants to go
it sounds like you'll need to have a
really really hard conversation before
you invest that kind of money in that
kind of time
almost a decade of his life into
something that
may not be his thing and it may be that
nursing school or nurse practitioner
school or
um like a you know a mental health
program or something is going to be more
his thing
but what i don't want you to do or let
me put it this way
complaining and nagging destroys
relationships it doesn't help accomplish
goals
and i know that's hard to hear but if
your husband
needs here's what he needs man he's a
safe place to say i do or don't want to
go to school
and here's how i would have that
conversation annika i would tell them
i love you more than anything in the
world
and you're a quiet compassionate soul
who loves me and our kids
and i am loud and maniacal and fun and
pushy and that's why you married me and
that's why i married you
everything about the last few years
shows me tells me that you don't want to
go to med school and
i don't want to force you into something
you don't want to do
it would be super fun to tell all my
friends i married a doctor then my mom
would finally get off my back that'd be
awesome
but if you don't want to do this i still
love you i'm still tethered to you i'm
still gonna
like be loud because that's how i live
my life but i want you to know i love
you
is this what you really want to do and
if he says no then if he says yes
then i want you to ask permission how
can i push you into this moving forward
how can i lean in and help you
because i'm tired of being your mom i
just want to be your wife i don't want
to be your
calendar person i want to be your
girlfriend i want to just be crazy
reckless in love with you and i want us
to have fun memories and i don't want
our childhood my care our kids to
remember
how i made you do calendar sessions
every day because that's not a
partnership man
and at some point y'all may have to just
grieve the loss of this grad school
dream of this med school dream
and make a new turn it doesn't sound
like he's
short of love and it doesn't sound like
he's short of hard work so like he's
busting his butt right now
it may be that med school is not for him
and here's the other thing he may have
worked his butt off for med school
and he didn't make it he didn't get in
that doesn't mean he's dumb that doesn't
mean he's not smart
that doesn't mean he's not whatever one
of the
things when i was a dean of students at
a law school i realized i couldn't do
this
i could have sacrificed my soul and got
through law school
but some of those kids were just smarter
than i was in certain ways
in different ways in the ability that
they could study for weeks and weeks and
weeks and weeks on end
i'm much more interested in being
engaged with people so i want a
different career route doesn't mean i'm
stupid doesn't mean that i don't have
hard work i don't have discipline no it
means
i was into something else but it sounds
like you need to sit down with him and
have a hard conversation and tell him i
want to be your wife
i want to be proud of you i want to love
you i want to be reckless
but i'm not going to be your mom anymore
and if med school's not the thing give
him permission to get off that hook
and if it's not then so be it and if
it's just that he tried his best and he
came up short love him anyway
okay love him anyway um
man he's gonna get into school that's
the thing he's gonna to get waitlisted
that's the cool thing they waitlist you
and see how bad you really want he's
going to get in
i want you all to have a hard
conversation about is this what you want
the next seven years of your life to be
med school's hard it's really really
hard thank you so much for the call
let's go to anna in
lakeland florida anna what's going on
hey how are you doing the best how about
you
i'm doing well awesome all right so
what's going on how can i help
well my husband and i have been married
for three years
okay we have a three-month-old little
boy whoo so you all are in it right
we're in it and adoring it loving it
it's amazing i love being a mom
oh so cool how long did y'all date
before you got married
a year okay okay so this is all real
fast huh
this is all real fast hey hi i love you
good to meet you let's get married let's
have a kid all right so you're in it so
now what
now what's going on yes so we might have
rushed a few things in getting married
in the word yeah when you
examine and go over goals in life and
different things
um it sounds a little bit different
before marriage than when you're putting
it into practice
yep and seeing it lived out yes yes yes
um
so i i've followed dave ramsey's plan
for a long time i'm debt-free i've
saved up an emergency fund and
he is he's a wonderful guy um has
struggled with
alcohol addiction issues okay um
sometimes that's still
in the present um and he is also
horrible
with money okay his financial plan is
give me whatever's left over
okay and um
and then i make up whatever difference
and he doesn't
he doesn't have money saved i know that
in a marriage you're supposed to join
bank accounts and those types of things
but there's not enough
trust to to give that over yet
on my side because i've been very
responsible and
i got a lot of reward and value from
working hard to get through dave's
program and so i can see from the other
side how valuable it is and i would love
for him to be able to
possess that and know that and work hard
but at the same time we're married and
supposed to be working together
and i don't i don't know how to do that
um yeah so
can i just get left with everything yeah
you're married to an addict
okay and um
here's the here's the the heartbreaking
dance y'all are in
addiction is a connection disorder okay
people get used substances or work or
sex
or whatever to
numb the fact that they're disconnected
from other people okay
and people have to protect themselves
from people who are addicts
because they're not reliable they're not
safe they aren't
um they don't show up they don't um
follow through et cetera
and so then people have to protect them
and what that means in a relationship is
i gotta unplug a little bit
sometimes a lot which then leads to more
addiction and then you see how the dance
goes
right correct at the end of the day
none of this works unless your husband
chooses to get clean
correct and he he works on it and um
he was clean before we got married and
then relapsed a few months into it and
has gone through a few of those cycles
part of it was my misunderstanding i
thought hey you get in a healthy
environment
and you get healthier but that's not the
case with addiction
and it's heartbreaking but yeah he
doesn't he's not getting the help
that he needs no matter what anyone
around him says
so i know it's up to him i can't do it
our son can't do it
right it's up to him and so i'm gonna
tell you to protect yourself and protect
your finances
and protect that little baby love love
love your husband
right and the what you need to do is
make sure you don't keep secrets okay
i want you to encourage him to get well
and to get healthy
and to create an environment for him
where it's okay for him like you know
what i mean like not making fun of him
and not getting onto him i know you
wouldn't i'm speaking more to people who
are listening right now
and not beating him up and telling what
a loser he is and all that kind of stuff
that doesn't help
an addict um but at the same time yeah
unfettered access to your checking
account and things like that will create
more and more mess down the road he's
going to have to decide to get clean
yes so how do you how do you like if he
has an emergency come up
do i just leave him on his own when he
hasn't been financially responsible
to no yeah you're his wife
and so you've got to plan for
contingencies right
um so at the same time i mean this is
just a messy situation for you
okay it is um yeah you if he's
give me an example of a messy sticky
situation he's gonna get himself into
um he had back pain and needed an
epidural which cost a thousand dollars
he does real estate photography and
crashed his drone
that's sixteen hundred dollars and i
didn't cover those things
because i just didn't want to because
i've covered a lot of other stuff
and then like um if he loses a job
or um when his back went out
i just got left with all the bills right
which
all right so it's hard so
you're here's where it's hard is you've
got a pronoun problem
and the pronoun problem is
his job his health his
insurance his money and y'all are
married this is y'all stuff
okay right yeah i know it's a pronoun
problem i don't like it
well you've got to start speaking that
way and he's gonna con
or he's never gonna feel connected and
um in a safe enough place to get well
and at the same time you've got to
protect yourself which sounds like i'm
talking out of both sides of mouth i
hope you can know what i'm talking about
here so here's
here's practical here's what this looks
like in real time
it looks like until you have committed
to sobriety
until you've committed to 30 or 60 days
of being completely sober
i'm not giving you access to all of our
money or
all of the pay all of the um the
household finances
i'm gonna i'm willing to step in the gap
here just like
if he got covered and was sick for three
weeks
you would step in the gap and do the
dishes every day right
you would help with the yard right so
whatever other agreement you'll have so
this is the same he's not
well he's in a season where he's not
well and so you are going to take care
of the finances for this season
but when he gets hurt it's y'alls
when he um doesn't show up to work it
hurts y'all's
bottom line not just his and yeah you
can't have your husband
laying in the next room over here like
with a back injury
that needs an epidural like well should
have saved your money bro me and the
baby are going out for pizza you can't
do that right i mean you could but
we got it taken care of i know but yeah
and i'm speaking i'm speaking broadly
here i'm not just saying you didn't word
that one right now i just
no i unders but i understand no no no i
mean you hate your husband we hear it um
i'm totally kidding but it's you're in a
mess
and the problem is is you're married to
an addict
at the end of the day you're married to
an addict and so you've got to find a
balance between
being connected and being letting noise
loved and he's safe
and you've got to take care of that baby
and you've got to take care of you
right at some point you have to have the
hard
and or conversation i mean the or if
conversation
you will get healthy you will get sober
or i'm going to have to make a dish
other plans
if his behavior hurts that child puts
that child in a position where he's not
safe
puts you in a position where you're not
safe then you're going to be forced into
making alternative um
arrangements right and that's a scary
scary place to be i i know that you look
close to that
are you yeah okay
um have you all gone to see somebody
together
um we've done marriage counseling but
obviously that's the issue that comes up
is what
um is the the root of
well not the complete route but one of
the roots of the problems is that that
part needs to be addressed
before you can have a healthy marriage
that's right and that they'll tell you
that in therapy right you both go into
therapists and they'll say hey when
you're sober then we can get to work
right
correct have you had a quiet
not angry not loud but a quiet
conversation
that lets him know that you love him and
it feels like you he is choosing alcohol
over you and his
new child oh yeah i've tried to have
that
regularly what's his response
um usually freezes up and won't say a
whole lot or
says hey i used to be drunk seven days a
week and now it's only four and you need
to celebrate it
anna i'm sorry i wish i had better news
for you
me too yeah that sucks
until he decides to make some
significant changes in his life
then it's going to be tough and what you
need to make sure is that baby is safe
and okay
that that baby doesn't grow up in the
home of yelling and screaming and
fighting
and lack of accountability because those
traumas imprint on a baby and they
are there for a lifetime okay correct
and he's my primary concern
our little boy is your little boy safe
yes okay very okay
well i'd love to talk to your husband if
he'll ever call in he probably won't but
if he did that'd be awesome
no you won't okay it would be i'd love
it yeah
well i i mean i love him i'm i'm sure
he's not well and i can almost guarantee
he would
prefer to not be drinking but until he
puts in the work then
um you've got some hard hard decisions
to make moving forward
i'm not gonna make those for you you're
gonna have to make those other than
if people are safe and you said y'all
are safe
um but until he chooses to get sober
um you can't trust him with the bank
accounts you can't trust him with the
jobs you can't trust him
um to build the future together because
it's just built on wobbly
wet sand and those things collapse
and so on we'll be thinking about you um
have one more hard conversation with
them okay or two
and uh i'm heartbroken for you i hate
those situations um
addiction just destroys everybody from
with from the addict on down man
oh man if you were struggling with an
addiction
please reach out to somebody that can
help you
four days of being drunk is not better
than seven
if you if you're an addict zero days is
better than seven
and if you're struggling man with
whatever it is with busyness with work
with alcohol with cocaine whatever it is
please reach out the people around you
love you
we love you and i want you to get well i
want you to be able to sleep at night i
want you to be
present with your kid and slowly start
to heal from the inside out
all right let's take one more call let's
go to um hmm
yeah let's go to philip in dayton ohio
phillip what's up man how can i help
how you doing sir all right brother i'm
doing good how about you
i'm doing well thank you for asking good
so what's up how can help
so i'm right into it uh my um dilemma is
i'm 24
and i live with my girlfriend we're
about to have a baby on the way okay
and uh i recently discovered you guys uh
i found you through dave ramsey and i
really like watching the show it will
help me um
get back to walking with the lord and i
really try to get my
life together again especially my
finances for a kid
but the problem is uh my girlfriend she
happens to be
uh atheist okay and i love my girlfriend
and
i want to marry her so we uh don't keep
living in sin
so i'm worried um as we keep going on
and developing
as a couple that she could keep
undermining me
and not maybe not want me to speak on
the lord so i don't know if it's okay to
marry her
uh as she's an atheist if i'm a
christian and she wants to keep waiting
as well
so what do you suggest i do
you ask me a whole bunch of questions
here and a couple of them
no you're all good bro it's a lot um
all at the outset i'm not gonna tell you
what to do here
okay right um here's
a couple of things you've got a baby on
the way that needs two parents who love
that baby is it a boy or girl
uh we don't know yet okay let's pretend
what do you want to be
i want to be a girl all right so i'm
going to say it's a little boy all right
so you got this little boy
just to mess with you so um this little
boy needs two parents that love him
okay love him more than anything on
planet earth that show up every single
day that love each other that talk
nicely and respect one another
that um
don't yell and scream and show up and
don't make
drama and deal with the challenges of
this crazy world together
right right that little baby boy needs
that
and deserves that and i'm telling you
right now philip he's gonna get that
right
yes sir okay so you and your wife have
different belief systems
about religion about god about
fill in the blank
if you have different beliefs that are
tethered to deep
deep values you can make things work
if you don't it's gonna be hard okay
so where do you think she's gonna i'm
gonna be back ask this way
does she regularly undermine you
not regularly but um how does she
undermine you
i say for example i would like to uh
raise my kid in the church
uh definitely doing that she would say
like uh she won't want to do that
so we'll see one thing will she prohibit
you from taking your kid to church on a
sunday
she hasn't flat out right said it but it
could be
definitely a possibility that she just
probably just said no it stopped one
time
she said like she would rather the kid
asked to go to church instead of me
starting up taking them well all that
kid's going to ask for for the first
three or four years
is um a new diaper food
hugs once he turns three or four he's
gonna wanna like
i don't know if it's a girl
i don't know i'm not gonna get into it
they're gonna watch tv don't let him do
it dude don't let him do it because then
it just changes everything right
um and don't ever let any of your kids
watch frozen because the rest of your
life will just be frozen related
um here's the thing you all need to get
with a
marriage counselor pronto all right
okay and you may say but i'm not married
we're not even engaged yet whether you
want to or not you are
connected to this woman for the rest of
your life
and what i will ask you for the sake of
that baby is that you all begin to work
together
on values are we going to be people of
integrity are going to be people who
um love our baby are we going to get
over petty stuff are we going to go over
little stuff or big stuff
and that's where i in for you a value
maybe
i will not marry someone who does not
believe in god
great then you need to cut the cord on
this
living together let her move on with her
life
and y'all figure out with the help of a
counselor what
um joint custody is going to look like
moving forward
okay if you love her and you all have
different beliefs about the afterlife
you all have very similar values
you're both people of integrity both
people who respect one another you're
both good human beings
and you believe in god you believe in
jesus and she doesn't
and i don't know why she would
whatever let my kid grow kid's three
dude kids too kids don't ask for that
kind of stuff
you teach your kids you let them grow up
in
value systems and community systems and
so that whole conversation gets me
frustrated man
but that's letting kids run the
household um
the same as a kid what do you want for
dinner honey here's what you're gonna
have for dinner
right because a three-year-old's gonna
pick ice cream and marshmallows every
time
and chicken nuggets and that's why they
need parents in their life to say no
i want you to have structure and values
and broccoli and fill in the blank but
that's a whole other phone call bro um
you all need to get together and find
out what your values are
and some of this like i don't know man
she may just
you need to have answers to those
questions asap okay
yes sir and the sooner you have answers
to those questions
um the more you can make concrete
decisions because what you're trying to
do is have the best of both worlds
you're having a baby with someone that
you probably love and care for is that
fair
yes okay you love her and care for her
and you're
a christian is that right yes sir okay
and she's not
and so you've you're feeling a
significant tension is she feeling this
tension at all or she looking at you
like dude what's wrong with you
why don't we just have this yeah she's
like she's looking at what's the problem
okay so i want you to get with a
counselor because my guess
is if she's looking at you that way your
values may be much more closely aligned
than you think they are
okay and i don't want you to use the
tension of
an upcoming birth of a child i don't
want you to
have the tension of um
she won't marry me right now i don't
want you to then
create this ecosystem where your kid's
gonna be born into a mess of stress
and chaos i also don't want you to get
married thinking i'll just figure this
out later
and that i'll she'll just come around
and she may not
okay yes sir so do the best you can to
get
real life answers and not just well i
think but get real
answers have a somebody that's a
professional that can walk you all to
through this okay and in the process
if you want to um
nobody's ever can like um
convince somebody to their particular
faith by
crushing them in an argument or
threatening them or putting their foot
on their neck right
right like the
old scripture they're gonna know we're
christians what a love we have for each
other
the church has lost to that sucker right
and so i don't think relationships are
doomed because
people have different beliefs they are
more complicated and they are hard
but if everybody goes into them with a
sense of mutual respect
then they can be overcome they can also
um not work at all from the outset and
you all just have to be grown-ups and
make those decisions
okay but you have to get over the best
of i want all this
all at the same time in the best of both
worlds it all works out for me
okay the reality is you got your
girlfriend pregnant and now things got
accelerated real fast
and y'all are gonna have to make some
real real grown-up decisions real real
fast
okay and no one's going to get
everything that they want in this deal
unless y'all both decide
for the sake of this baby for the sake
of one other we love each other we're
going to continue to learn and grow in
our values our beliefs are going to
shift and change and that's okay that's
called growing up that's called wisdom i
hope my beliefs change a thousand times
in my lifetime
but i want my values to stay completely
rooted and um
uh does that make sense yes sir it does
okay
so what's your next step
next step is to go see somebody like a
counselor no your next step is this okay
you're gonna go see her tonight and i
want you to look her in the eye and once
you put your hands on
the side of her face on both sides okay
okay and i want you to tell her i love
you with all my heart
i love our little baby delony this dude
on the radio thinks it's gonna be a boy
but
i'm hoping it's a girl and
um i want us to go get some answers to
our relationship
sooner rather than later and so i'm
going to make some phone calls tomorrow
to find us a good
relationship counselor will you please
go with me
because i love you i know you love me
and we love this baby
and faith is super super important to me
it's not going to change
and um your atheism may be really
important to you but i want to dig into
where we can
find common values for the sake of this
baby and if we need to call the
relationship then we need to call it
okay okay and that's hard what i just
asked you to do philip that's hard
that's that's you putting some either
oars man
but i'm telling you right now having a
baby
and still not knowing where you stand
relationally man just
is a recipe for a life of chaos okay
and a life of chaos is the last thing a
baby needs the baby needs two parents
that love
love and cherish each other and love and
love and cherish
him or her all right so as we wrap up
man
uh thanks for that call phillip as we
wrap up um this song is from an album
that i loved the self-titled album back
in 2002
from the used it's one of my favorite
songs of all time it's called bury
myself alive and it goes like this
you almost always pick the best times to
drop the worst lines
you almost made me cry again this time
another false alarm red flashing lights
well this time i'm not going to watch
myself die i think i made it a game to
play your game
and let myself cry and i buried myself
alive on the inside so i could shut you
out
and let you go away for a long time
and i guess it's okay i puked the day
away and i guess it's better you trapped
yourself in your own way
and if you want me back you're gonna
have to ask
that's it if you want me back you're
gonna have to ask
people just ask this is the dr john
dolone show
you